the Joe Rogan experience I don't I don't
do edibles mm-hmm-hmm hilarious why I
was in college a Kenyan college in 1973
my dad was coming to visit and one of my
one of my the people on the floor at
this dormitory they made some marijuana
brownies oh boy and I had never think we
starts that way I ate two brownies I got
my dad's coming in two or three hours so
what the heck and I was so frigging
stoned I could not believe it and I
could barely keep my eyes were really I
was trying to trying to maintain it you
know how it is you're trying to look
like you're not stoned but you're
blitzed out of your gourd and so I would
my dad was like you're looking at me
really curiously this is ninety nineteen
seventies and so the next day I said dad
I got to tell you something I I ate some
marijuana brownies he goes I knew
something was wrong I knew I could tell
what I could tell I don't know [ __ ]
Sherlock I'm finally on the floor yeah
but it was it's but marijuana that he
came out of you know he was actually
amused and delighted that I explained to
him why I look so stoned
oh well that's great that you had that
kind of communication yeah just before
before he died he wanted to trip on
mushrooms and uh and I turned him down
because it was close to the end of his
life and he was very religious and I was
concerned I would shake his reality tree
so severely that he would question his
entire life because he was like a Death
of a Salesman figure is a tragic life
that he led and the mushrooms could have
helped him enormous Lee but I was a
concern that he would look back and goes
I wasted my life so that was too much of
too heavy for me you know maybe I am
maybe I'm being selfish because I was
trying to protect my own feelings but he
wanted to do it he asked me actually he
said I wanna I want to do suicide
mushrooms with you and he wouldn't smoke
pot do you have regrets about that but
not doing it with him I do I have I have
a lot of regrets about that so I I have
met several people in the past several
weeks at Stanford Medical School at
these other conferences that I go to
which there's a brain mind conference at
Stanford Medical School in the first two
sentences they mentioned psilocybin
hundred and twenty neuroscientists you
know and 150 billion dollars in the room
and psilocybin was immediately mentioned
and when I met some people there that
are intergenerational grandparent parent
an 18 19 year old child all journeyed
with mushrooms together and their
interpersonal relationships they told me
you know there's no reason for us ever
to get mad at each other I just thought
that was really powerful Wow
yeah that is powerful that sounds
inconceivable to someone who's never
experienced psychedelics but someone who
has you go yeah I see how you could get
there don't make mountains out of
molehills yeah you know you can disagree
without being angry and you can be civil
about it yes well that's a less in the
world could use right now I think this
is in many ways the antidote for some of
the problems that we're seeing with
social media one of the problems we see
with social media is this disconnect
from the human experience disconnect
from communication person-to-person
communication and this anger and vitriol
and look at hate and Heidi behind screen
yes you know your Joe Rogan I'm Paul
Stamets yeah well who are these people
hide behind screen names I just and a
great TED talk which I did not
understand and the TED talk was
fantastic talking about why trolls do
the things that they do they do it
because they get excitement sure the
idea is just to disturb the fabric and
the more disturbance they get that is a
measure of their success yes and
provoking a response even if they're not
wedded to it I just want to be able to
cause a ripple in the pond yeah and well
they don't feel significant so they want
to do something that they can get some
sort of reaction they have a rock they
see a window they want to throw it it's
it's a natural inclination but it's
stupid it's barbaric it's fun but it's
at least a [ __ ] time you know and
some people celebrated I'm like okay
celebrate it you're not doing [ __ ]
you're not doing [ __ ] for yourself
you're not doing [ __ ] for other people
you're not improving
whatever your art is whatever your
whatever whatever it is that you you try
to do in this life to leave your mark or
to contributor to be creative you're not
doing that if you're trolling it's not
all troller should eat mushrooms
yes well I'm all angry people should be
mushroom doesn't that's true I really
agree with that
[Applause]